[Music]
it's time for et's late-night roundup
your quick catch up on all the best
celebrity scoop after dark it was insane
on Jimmy Kimmel Live Emma Watson opened
up about attending the Los Angeles
premiere of her new film Beauty and the
Beast
and the star that had her completely
starstruck Dion arrives
oh yeah my publicist like this is almost
too much Celine Dion was me this is your
first time meeting Celine you have to
understand like my parents do not then
doll they really understand God like
celebrities will Hollywood or whatever
else but my mom and I used to play slin
Dion in the car like non-stop oh really
and yeah being able to tell her that I
met her I was like she's gonna lose it
and did she indeed lose it or she did
but I'm also proud I'm so proud over on
The Late Late Show
Emma's former Harry Potter co-star
Rupert Grint told host James Corden that
he often gets mistaken for Ed Sheeran
it's kind of 50/50 now it's like right
no one stops me it's it could it could
go either way I could be aired or it
could be me yes yes sir he came he came
up to me and said he loved my music of
course thinking I was Ed yeah I just
yeah I play alone him coming now for the
manly
you